I think that men are not well adjusted
in the society and women are not trying
to re-embody what they have built for us
I think that like what we're forgetting
is a very important detail which is just
like human respect and dignity yeah and
not asking people to prove what their
experience is and to prove to you like
it is like such conservative thinking to
say like I don't understand explain it
to me versus just saying I don't
understand and let me respect what you
are saying You're Expecting wherever
your starting point I'm respecting that
I'm really respecting that I'm saying
that if you don't have the mindset you
can even achieve it you're never going
to even try so it's better achieve what
like what are we talking about because I
feel like they projected this like
capitalist ideology on every woman
achieve whatever it is you're looking
for equality Equity but what I'm saying
is women in the feminist space in a lot
of these other spaces we don't
acknowledge that we have to take the
initiative